[Music]
I'm so bored I'm so bored I'm still
bought I'm so bored
I'm so balls hey guys you bored
how about we go on a plane and fly to
the UK and go fishy well here we go guys
we're doing another adventure we're
heading to the UK for 3 weeks we're
gonna be hitting England Scotland
fishing saltwater freshwater carps
sharks eels catfish it's going to be an
adventure
hey there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah you hold a Jacob I well guys we
made it we're in London we met up with
my sister Melanie here who's gonna be
joining us on our trip and we can get
the rental car and I'm gonna see if I
can remember how to drive on the left
side of the road all right guys we
decided to get a little fancy and I
rented a mercedes-benz it holds nine
passengers and all their luggage
this thing's a beast all right oh this
looks so weird guys all right we're
doing this and this is this is the gear
shift okay I haven't slept in a while
but this whole left-hand side of the
thing has got me so freaked out it's
keeping me wide awake okay so I think I
found the British equivalent of I hot to
go to breakfast at we're gonna see if we
can't get there without dying
but these are the most teeny tiny
parking spots okay I've got myself a
proper English breakfast here stewed
tomatoes beans eggs bangers potatoes oh
I'm looking forward to this if he can't
get sleep food is a nice alternative all
right we're leaving London we're heading
west to the county of Devon to a village
called Chumley and it's about three
hours and 20 minutes west of us
we just drove through the birthplace of
Jane Austen
all right we pulled over to get some
snacks cuz I'm running on 24 hours with
no sleep and we've got a bunch of
pineapple Fanta
and we've got jaffa cakes and gummy
caterpillars no driving to the cottage I
look up and hey look there's Stonehenge
on the side of the highway
chillin on the side all the way yeah
that's cool and all but I've been to
foam head
well we left our house 20 hours ago and
we're finally here this is pretty cool
let me show you this place
it's the Riverside cottage at the Parc
Mills farm it's converted barn this
place is just gorgeous and charming and
it's got its own private carp fishing
lake and a Fly Fishing Creek right here
on the property that we can access as
much as we want oh that is way cool oh
oh this is awesome
nice little kitchen so this is the
master bedroom right here look at this
and hey Becca check this out we go right
out here and right there is the lake
right through the trees and lay this Fly
Fishing Creek with some native trout in
there look at its back deck you know a
place we can build the fire out of all
the wonderful features about this
cottage one of my favorite is that the
owner made us some fresh scones and left
them on the table look at those beauties
this is like the keys to Hogwarts castle
here look at those cool well the boys
have some fun and everyone get situated
I'm gonna run to the grocery store and
get provisions for the week I'm on my
way to the grocery store and I've had a
little bit of a breakdown
apparently this mercedes-benz needs
something called AdBlue and it ran out
of it and so now a car will only drive
12 miles per hour and it will shut off
unless it gets some AdBlue in the next
24 miles so I'm gonna
an hour driving 12 miles per hour to get
to the nearest gas station to go buy
some and blue to put it in the car to
hopefully get it working these very nice
people here have given me a ride and I
wouldn't bought a whole bunch of this a
blue stop and I think I think we just
might get this car to go over 12 miles
per hour yet well thanks to my new
friends here we got a blue in the car
we're up and running and things seem to
be working
those two people spent a good 45 minutes
an hour driving me around getting that
out blue and helping me out man just
absolute wonderful people here let's go
get some groceries it's gonna be a long
week and we're gonna want some good food
it is pork and pickled pie and Scotch
eggs well we're finally here settled in
and got the kids to bed I'm gonna go
over here
check out this lake look at this pond
it's actually picturesque what I think
of British carp fishing ponds this is
this is what I think of oh man this
fishings got me so excited but it's too
late tonight so I'm gonna get to sleep
and we'll see you guys this is the best
day ever seen sheep on a trip a lot of
places with private lakes they'll do day
tickets where you can pay to come and
fish here you can only fish it if you
rent one of the cottages so it gets very
little fishing pressure look at this
pond there's carp in here oh right there
I can see a big pile of mud being kicked
up right there look it's like I found it
that's Louise hey chump look down here
gorgeous
oh just one again I am really excited to
go fish that pond in the stream it just
looks so gorgeous and I'm gonna be doing
a lot of filming over there
all right we're here it's time to go to
church but we're not gonna be long that
we got done with Church and my absolute
favorite part is that there's cows right
outside the window while we're in church
pretty awesome pretty cow we're not
doing a ton of stuff today I'm not
really going fishing or anything just
kind of trying to keep it low-key and
spend time with the family so we're a
road trip and I've got some off-brand
jammie Dodgers and some pork pies and
we're just gonna cruise around and enjoy
the countryside
[Music]
well we're here in Exmoor National Park
and we're just gonna take a little walk
to something called the Tarr steps which
is like a little bridge across the river
or something
Jacob you having fun no
well there we go this is the tower steps
this is beautiful what man there's a lot
to see here other than just big cities
well Becca's leg is still not 100% so I
will get the car and drive down and pick
her up
[Laughter]
well that was a fun drive but we gotta
get these kids to bed I'll see you guys
in the morning we're doing some fishing
tomorrow well good morning and welcome
to a beautiful day I woke up with a
little bit of light coming through the
window and I had no clue what time it
was but it was like Christmas morning I
was too excited and I am determined to
pull a carp out here before breakfast
there's fish jumping all over the place
now if you want to know more about what
I'm doing which gear I'm using and how I
fish this spot a lot more footage of the
fishing I'm gonna be posting a video on
my other channel the catfish and carp
YouTube channel of just about fishing
this pond so I'll put a link in the
description to that a carp came over
just started feeding right there I swear
he was in ten inches from the shore well
I've been fishing here for a couple
hours gotten tons of bites but nothing's
really hooked up but that's okay I've
got a whole week here so I'm taking it
easy we got bacon and sausage and toast
and beans and oh yeah I've been looking
forward to this every sausage should be
sold like this well there we go guys a
proper English breakfast oh I'm so
hungry well we had a lovely but slow
morning and now we're gonna go out and
about and do a little shopping and maybe
do a little sightseeing as well
we stopped to get gas I picked up some
snacks gummy eggs gummy hearts
gummy bears and gummi Cola bottles
[Music]
alright we're here at Sigma which
appears to be the home of a massive Folk
Festival so it's crawling people but we
found parking we get out and we'll get
back of some painting stuff awesome now
me and Becca have a tradition that every
time we go to a foreign country we try
to buy a kids book from that country so
you'll see if we can't find a nice
British kids book here divided where'd
you get I got dog man and leaves there
we go
well that little parades jammed up the
road so while we wait we're gonna be
very American and eat our food in the
car so as an apple pork Cornish pasty
very nice
yeah we're driving through a river
drive-through you know it
always fit most today driving around and
seeing science but we want to catch some
fish so we're gonna go hit the pond
again beautiful stocky little British
common car caught on some bread right on
the surface but I just watched him suck
it up just 10 12 feet from me and he's
released good job Tommy well it's the
end of my first full fishing day here in
the UK and I'm sitting here eating a
samosa and some tikka masala after
having landed a few carp and I just had
a ball my god I'll see you guys in the
morning
good morning and once again I find
myself up at 5 a.m. and this time I'm
going down to new K to go out of the
harbour to go shark fishing on a charter
unfortunately it's supposed to be rough
seas so Nathan and Tommy aren't coming
with me
but we're gonna go see what happens
pretty town there's our boat the
Atlantis it's about to take us out into
the Atlantic Ocean to go fishing for
sharks
hi I'm doing well
we've left new cave we're heading out
about ten miles offshore
it's tough I feel better get these in
Alaska this one artificial
well we caught the crap out of the
mackerel and got a bunch of pulling but
the Sharks were just a bit too finicky
today we get back to the harbor and
we're going to clean up those Pollock
and I'm gonna make some fish chip
all right
see you ned check it out this place is
gorgeous man look at the seals down
there so gals crabbing this is pretty
cool so check it out this is why they
dropped me off at that other location
you'd see the harbor's high and dry now
that's where his boat was parked
well I finally made it home and my
stomach won and a breakfast do-over so
I'm eating some cereal with raspberries
with hombre Jacob and it's good to be
home
strawberry toast and bacon sandwich
breakfast of champions we're ready to
leave and Nathan ran out naked screaming
do you wanted to come too so we got him
dressed as getting him buckled Athens
along for the ride
alright guys we're here at Combe valley
angling and we're gonna see if we can't
pick up some some gear here does the
phrase kid in the candy store comes to
mind here holy mackerel look at all
these yeah you like that and I love
being in these stores unfortunately I
can't be here too long because Tommy and
Nathan are gonna burn the place down if
I stay here - all right guys we're gonna
do a little sightseeing we're gonna hit
an old manor house and a museum and just
go for a little road trip
[Music]
all right I have no idea what we're
doing it this is kind of Melanie's thing
so where we going to some manor houses
yeah a big old manor house that also
happens to house the national carriage
museum my sister is a novelist and
writes bonnet smut which is period
romance and she's doing research what
are you doing let's go look at that
water I wonder if they speak
[Music]
that crazy look how black that water is
[Music]
[Music]
look
that's one of the first selfie sticks
ever invented the camera on a tripod
[Music]
[Music]
smile
in the front doors sneak out the back
that's how we roll all right guys let's
go over to the t card I'm gonna get a
little bit uh get a scone or something
in athan so we got wild elderflower
bubbly and rhubarb crush now we got some
strawberry jam and clotted cream try
this just take a bite you like that
we looked at traveling birds yeah look
at that side there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well you did a little sightseeing and
now we're gonna go ahead a bakery you
guys decided you hungry
oh yeah
on the way back to the farm we stopped
in Barnstable to get a Cornish Hot
Pocket also known as a Cornish pasty
here this one's uh meat potato good
alright we just got done with
sightseeing and I'm back here at the
pond I'm gonna try to pull a few fish
out there we go look at that beautiful
little Carmen lover want a dinner but I
think that's called a Rudd right there
well don't put them back in only get on
with you Owen
oh that's a nice one
got it big fish oh it's pooping it's
gonna do - yeah that isn't that nice
yeah - back it okay yeah go for it put
them back in alright guys we're back in
the house we got a bag full of fresh
Pollock we're gonna make some fish and
chips if you want to know the recipe
with all the details I'll put it in the
video description
my thanks there you go how's the fish
it's good hmm oh darn hot well good
morning everybody and once again I'm
headed to a new key Harbor and this time
I'm pronouncing it a little bit better
I'm gonna be Matt we really go have
another crack at some brie fish and some
shark see what happens well I'm just a
few minutes outside of nuki and I'm
stuck behind a horse traffic jam noogies
this lovely little beach town on palm
trees and sunshine and cliffs and
beaches mornin
how we doing I'm doing great Oh looks
wonderful this is Lauren hey Lauren
there we go there we go got the anchor
dropping all right we just anchored up
near a rack and we're gonna be targeting
conger eel which are these massive eels
that live in the ocean around England
there we go oh there's definitely
something Wiggly on hand to this maybe
that's quite a pull pull yeah oh my
goodness see that Princess Bride there
look at that that is so cool
well there we go my very first conger
eel there we go
angry angry looking shark look at those
teeth oh I don't think I've ever had a
fish want a piece of me as badly as this
guy he just seemed straining with
everything he's got to turn around and
get your bite you somewhere
that's a three there we go that's my
first sea bream the black bream blue you
there I just put them back no I would
but well there you go buddy all right
Louie go oh it started to rain it's
pretty close to the end of the day
anyways so I think it's time we're gonna
call it well guys I had a great time if
you guys want to see more details about
the fishing part of this trip check out
my other channel the catfish and carp
YouTube channel I'll put a link in the
description and if you guys want to go
on this trip make sure to check out new
key fishing trips code okay I'll put a
link in the description for more
information
oh look guys that was a lot of fun
I am wet and hungry though we got to get
all the way back up to Devon and if I'm
lucky am I gonna do some carp fishing
tonight this city is absolutely
beautiful it's harbors amazing I would
love to come back here and just fish the
key pain grab some food at the grocery
store and I've got some sort of kebab
wrapped in flatbread and a pork pie so
there we go man dinner of Champions
[Music]
we've got one last night here at the
cottage and we want to catch a carp
don't we what do you think is that cool
well Tommy did you have a good time
fishing yeah have you had fun at this
cabin
to leave yeah but we're gonna have
really fun at the next place we go now
let's get you to bed it's your super
late and I'll see you guys in the
morning if you like this video don't
forget to check out part 2 of our
three-week long fishing tour of the UK
where we go to the Midlands and don't
forget to click subscribe to the outdoor
boys YouTube channel we put out new
videos every Saturday morning
you
[Music]